[Music]
what's going on there reject nation greg
johnny coy here we're about to watch
miss marvel the first episode he and you
love miss love miss marvel you've read
like all the comics every single issue i
think she's the modern day silver age
spider-man i think she has a lot of
those parallels we'll talk about that
after the episode and she represents you
culturally i mean when i think about me
i think young muslim american woman
from new jersey very much those things
fortunate enough to get to watch this
early but the background's a little
different than it has been lately
because uh i i've moved look we've
traveled through the quantum realm isn't
that fascinating very minimalist
comparatively guys uh full length watch
longer secret with the time code
available for our super sexy rejects
over at our patreon page cover bunch of
shows over there exclusively reaction
highlights included at the same tier
thank you guys for shower support also
if you can't join us on our patreon
leave a like in your thoughts down below
in the episode helps us out of the
algorithm yay youtube algorithm they're
the best and subscribe click that
notification bell get notified when our
next reaction for uh miss marvel is up
and while you're at if you've got some
downtime go check out koi's comic corner
which i'm hoping is a successful weekly
segment or bi-weekly segment by this
point uploading this video then boys at
where john prepper thank you so much for
editing down these highlights for making
us look good and hey if you guys need
some editing help hit them up but just
wait until they're done cutting our
stuff yeah we come first always
narcissus
[Music]
the final chapter to my temper series on
earth's mightiest hero captain marvel
alien ships invading fans being a jerk
about magical stones our heroes were
done for
until
[Laughter]
i know some of you think well she
abandoned the people of earth but like
look it's not true
maybe we'll learn something new at
avenger con this week avenger con
interesting
anyway that's all i got for this week
next week i'm going to kick off a
special two-part series on why i think
thor is secretly a gamer
kamala please don't forget to look at
the mirrors every 15 seconds that these
turns oh kamala my kamala the road is a
long and winding one so never fully stop
it stop sight
just make sure that the instructor can
see you move your head and remember to
say bismillah before you start the car
you're gonna need all the help you can
get don't even have a license
it's very very echo right
bless you
[Applause]
i'm not coming anyone's thought
[Laughter]
oh come on are you trying to tell me she
didn't look in the mirrors often enough
for you and your clipboard
camina give me my keys
okay kamala come
least they look after this is my fault
this is all my fault for my genetics
there's some fun little artisan writer
easter eggs on that are you inviting me
over to play smash bros because if so
i'm i'm busy don't hate the player hate
the game the thing is i do hate the game
hate the big glove
sorry zoe fine
i like your jacket
thanks i like your necklace uh thanks
it's actually my name in arabic
while concrete please come to my office
asap you've done something very wrong
i'm just kidding it's crazy that the
whole school's been here
they're telling me you're doodling all
day staring off into space in your
little fantasy lounge hey
oh really we truly started the meeting
30 seconds ago you got to be with me
girl
mr wilson was my father my name is gabe
his name was also gabe so
[Laughter]
time to start really thinking about your
future i mean college admissions are
coming up before you know it it's sats
it's essays it's application man that
normal [ __ ] is boring in the marvel
world it's interesting that you have to
make it approachable but it's also like
we're watching a girl in high school i
see a girl divided is she there is she
there where's kamala
and i know i know fantasy's fun fantasy
is really fun but right now
i need you to pull yourself together
and join reality
how does it feel certain stop it's a
very interestingly constructed shot just
there
it reminded me of rules of attraction
but in reverse this is the first one
ever right and then future historians
they're going to start writing about
this year of adventure condom where does
it start
here
okay it's not going to be another first
avenger calling ever again never
i really like her performance a lot
she's very natural so natural
and just like every single thing i love
she seems to hate and it's it's like she
thinks i'm some kind of you know weirdo
you are a world but more importantly
i've gotten weirdly good at airbrushing
flirts like you about comics
with skills
like airbrushing it's not to like
works i am sure it was a compliment
thank you
okay i can't build you a horse but
otherwise you could build me slap baby
wings you know that's very neat
completely you
wings little tiara
captain princess no princess i'm sorry
but you know what's even better what
zombie captain marvel i could be like
this is so cool
okay hey let's never do that zombie
impersonation again
wowie
so it's like
watching the movie that inspired the
show
i thought that was an old woman i didn't
recognize that's my kid
is michael sarah
you know michael sarah can play
allen the fourth golden girl michael
sarah
ahmed have you lost your years
this is so cool is this nannies
that
is
jump
oh she knows what that is
what happened she decided that she
wasn't ready for commitment so now she's
off gallivanting through europe to
discover herself good for her
i mean she wanted to travel the world
and she went for it
she's trouble with this one
she's going to discover that she doesn't
have a ring on her finger that's what
she's going to discover that's what
matters most
yeah absolutely so this is a security
camera okay so you can see who's home
from your phone
from my phone oh yeah from the phone
we're living in the future
[Laughter]
zoo zoo
turn off the lights
[Music]
are you staying for dinner no no i got
some work okay i'll pack you something
to go no no i'm good no no of course i
will
did you ask her about adventure god
come on ask her just ask her no
there's a spicy one at the bottom
do that so fast
you stick to the gizmos beta this is my
secret
superpower
so there's this thing called avengercon
fan events celebrating our great heroes
of our time and bruno's um
he's like really into this stuff you
know so
he really wants to go and um wow
is this a joke no is bruno recording
this for internet
look i promise i won't do anything
stupid
you you do trust me right no i don't
trust you
how exactly will you be dressed huh cat
please please
and but me no because i can't do a
single normal teenage thing in this
house right
you're not normal
you know all she does to me say no it's
like
where is this out of proportion worry
for you i'll talk to them yeah i mean
you look kind of but yeah
i love how much there's a purple
aesthetic to this show
i it's like one of the like this and
moon knight i think the most uniquely
formatted like
that felt like just an error and this
feels like whoever directed it it's so
stylized yeah it's a really nice visual
language great color palette
[Music]
and like this circle cue and like all
the visuals are right from the books
totally yeah they totally read koi
well like circle q is kind of like the
daily bugle like it's it's it's part of
the dna of the comics so it's really
cool to see them like focus on it
exactly yes
i'm glad you're finally picking up on
that
[Music]
who did carol danvers pose for
where did they get that photo
artist reenactment
we have decided
to let you go
your abu will drive you there and he
will go inside with you for two hours
and as far as your dressing goes
i have a surprise please
war machine oh the hulk oh my god
[Laughter]
no
it's amazing
there's no big hulk little hulk it's not
at all this is mine and bruno's thing
okay come on buddy can't wear
shortcomings to avenger con okay and and
you can't come with me not just like
that because it is so humiliating
dude he's cosplaying he looks great if
you don't go with your dad you're not
going at home you're not going to dress
up like all those other girls in skimpy
outfits that is not you
so kamala kills her mom in the comics
right yep okay
no power and then he hulks out
they're
villains they're not going
damn it you lost your ally
a lot of this strangely
reminds me of my filipino culture side
stressing out this captain marvel's
weird
no it's not and it's childish and i know
that okay and and let's be honest it's
not really the brown girls from jersey
city who saved the world
sure they do
you're kamala khan
you want to save the
world
then you're gonna save them all
are you imagining this
with the red equipment
god you made these yeah do you like them
yes
oh bruno corelli corporation i like it
has a nice ring to it
how do they turn on right here wow
[Music]
she just seems like such a real girl i
know
i keep i keep getting lost in like she
seems so real
[Music]
time to go full carry
please switch the tv
kamala please tell bruno the zuzu is
possessed by the evil gina
switch it on
if i can't leave the house to go to
avenger con i'll go to adventure come
without leaving the house
this is the plan kamala you're the best
sister ever honestly you should have
been an only child
5 55 i suit up in the greatest captain
marvel costume the earth has ever seen
and like then i make my way out of the
house undetected but extremely
impressive you will be waiting in your
country
but what if your parents go into your
room
so when there's a knock on the door
finally you being a genius is coming in
handy
what do you mean finally
catch the bus to camp lehigh it might be
a tight window but we're going to do it
with styles
wait is that a spiking off a bridge onto
a bus
[Laughter]
then it's time for a tight but
spontaneous 60 minutes of fun at
avengercon
[Music]
cosplay competition i win obviously
collect my crown i'm assuming it's made
of real diamonds i'll sneak back into my
room just before my dad comes in at 9 22
pm
that's the plan so your plan is
take the bus
[Music]
you know what she seems up with captain
marvel in the future is gonna be pretty
sweet
[Music]
nope
you're doing good kamala
[Music]
oh my goodness
[Laughter]
ow
oh that was my way back in no we missed
the bus
we can still make the next one but if we
miss it it's game over
[Music]
of
[Music]
you course the infinity stones on the
spokes
i wish we did conventions out here that
celebrated superheroes
like san diego would be a good spot or
woodland hills
woodland hills con let's go
[Music]
the song
was great thanks oh my god smashed
somewhere any rock stars heads are
exploding right now
pause everything is that an early
she-hulk or a black widow i couldn't
tell i think it was gamora
definitely
[Laughter]
america
[Music]
wow it's becoming the boys
monetizing our superheroes
hey drax costumes cool
asgard pride
for valkyrts that's good
[Music]
[Laughter]
no
destroy her why is she here
the costume's not even accurate she
doesn't even like the avengers i know
it's okay it's okay okay
i think that's a great costume
you have the gloves yeah they're in my
bag
let's straighten that out come on it's a
contest
last call for the captain marvel cosplay
competition cosplayers please line up on
the side of the stage
no
no give it up amazing captain america
cosplayers thank you
cosplayers
smashed
the details in the background are
fantastic
i can't get it on it's like still for
some reason
where are the gloves okay just
crap i left it in the bathroom
but he made the gloves dude fine
you got the bangle
put it on
just jam it on
[Music]
[Applause]
pakistani bengals bite
[Music]
wow
i got chills
oh damn she just goes like full center
stage
[Music]
oh my god kamala what have you done he's
gonna kill everyone
[Music]
she's gotta win she's gotta win she's
gotta win now yep
oh no big hand and biggin
oh
[Music]
that's not that big a deal just
sprinklers
oh people are dying
i don't know
what are you available to book for
parties do you want to take a picture
i'll tag you i fall back mostly
oh my god
they just killed zoey
[Music]
[Applause]
wait are you available for parties or
not
just happened what just happened i don't
even know what to say
i can't believe it i actually have
powers
it's amazing
don't stop okay i'd never sell anyone
never ever
never ever ever
really really there's some great camera
work in this show
ah [ __ ] whoa
yep
who is this rebellious girl
sneaking out
do you want to be good or or do you want
to be some you know this cosmic
head in the clouds person
both
you think about that
i remember giving that same speech to
koi
yeah i didn't take it well
yeah i stopped sneaking out for avengers
cons though
most of the art in the background is
comic authentic and there's a terry
dodson piece they keep using that's
great that's exactly what we talked
about
good job remembering those details
[Music]
cosmic
she's made a choice
oh that's right the guys who did bad
boys three right yeah i'd forgotten that
[Music]
that's a normal statue of liberty yeah
new york not the cap statue of liberty
oh that's true well it fell yeah i
noticed that it's regular
wayne street
that's a oh hey batman's family dude
comic books are all connected
a cosplayer with too much time on their
hands not this one i've never seen
powers like that
yeah bring her in
oh kamala's law is coming kamala's law
is coming she's going to need a good
lawyer
daredevil is going to be at all the
shots
very good lawyers catching bricks
through many windows
originally there are snow globes where
they return them into bricks and posts
you guys know that yeah because of the
shape of his hand and all that stuff can
you believe
white people wrote and directed that
whoa what really yeah i thought i
thought the brothers that directed i
don't know i don't know they were pure
white didn't you catch their names
samuel and william
i don't judge my names my name's coy
whiteman
we are all white men except for you that
was very charming that was i i'm really
impressed uh i will say it's we're not
reviewing it yet credits we gotta fade
a little little wipe here to let the
audience know if this that's divided
watching the credit section's different
john wipe it white hey look we got fancy
dancy mics we're not gonna talk for too
long though that's what i always say
yeah absolutely won't talk for too long
he's always wrongly talked for too long
is that right koi
anyway i was really charmed by this a
lot i think uh it goes without saying
that the visual style i mean is
obviously very it's kind of felt like a
splice of what was that hayley steinfeld
movie edge of seven true grey
17
and uh scott pilgrim versus the world a
little bit of both but i also did like
how committed they were to the cultural
influence what is their exact background
pakistani she's pakistani but she's the
first muslim superhero like to headline
up a comic ever or yeah
like i'm not pakistan some people think
i'm from some people think i'm pakistani
or indian or mexican or i'm all kinds of
anything but irish anything but irish is
what i get growing up filipino in
california you're surrounded by a lot of
like cultural clashes of wanting to
express yourselves and you know and and
go do your own thing have your own
freedom but then you could feel like
kind of the oppressive very disciplined
you have to live by the parents uh rules
because you know it's a lot i'm like a
lot of us out here like first generation
you know with the kamala khan situation
so i really identified with that aspect
there are other qualities i'm sure that
you can probably identify with and koi
is just the biggest fan
of us
of course the superhero fantasy side of
being obsessed i'm sure he can identify
with so i think
there's there's quality because before
this before watching this sometimes
you're like it's only just for kids just
for little kids and i don't know i
thought this was actually really
charming i didn't find it hilarious and
i wasn't like swept up in wonder yet i
was
very very charmed throughout and there's
a lot i really appreciate i think it's
so composed every shot seemed like it
was so purposeful like it seemed like
there was a real shot list of the way
this was
executed that it did have me curious
what was the prep like beforehand
because they must have had to storyboard
this out like crazy whereas the other
ones i'm sure you have a shot list but
maybe not as storyboarded but this felt
like it had to be just with the amount
of integration they had but uh and and
the other main thing too is
uh this iman velani actress
holy [ __ ] she's gonna be able to keep up
with everybody she was fantastic she is
so good she's so it feels like i'm i'm
watching like a real kid uh one of those
real nerdy kids out here you know you
know marvel can pull off
visuals they can pull up aesthetic they
can pull off a fun tone and whatever but
to capture the essence of this character
was
the most impressed i was was with her
performance i couldn't ever everyone's
good everyone's so natural but her
especially was like you seem so real i
kept getting that's the thing that i was
getting swept up in the most was how
real she she seemed now it's time to see
like the real dramatic half scenes can
she cry on camera that's the mark of a
good actor that's all it really takes
it's crying nikoi i know you're gonna
like hog the mic so much just hold on
for a second john
get in there what did you identify with
what did you think point out something
different that i didn't point out go for
it john i really loved this uh first
taste of the show partly because it felt
like i
some of the shows feel more like you're
watching an episode of something or like
a show and this felt like i just watched
a piece of a movie it was really really
gracefully composed and they have a lot
of setup to do and you're in a familiar
world but i thought that they really
really did a nice job of establishing a
tangible and a cultural tone that feels
very alive like iman vilani anchors
everything with just that incredibly
natural charisma but even beyond that
just the way in which they realize new
jersey and the convention and just the
time and place of everything
felt like a great convergence of some
indie movie with the marvel cinematic
universe flavors and i love love loved
the way they composed everything from
the visuals to the music but but really
just that you know that look in that
aura like it's got great color and it's
got really beautiful striking again
composed shots that really feel like you
said intentional i feel like especially
now we're at a point where people are
sort of expecting marvel to upgrade and
be more expressive with their visual
palette and their emotional palate and i
think that this speaks to that whereas
certain other things have maybe you know
struggled i felt like this was really
colorful and really beautiful and it
uses that scott pilgrim style animated
you know heightened world to great
effect without making me sit here and go
you just got pilgrim you know
so so yeah i i really love it and hey
you know yeah white guy blah blah blah
whatever but i totally related to kamala
khan and just the situation she's in
even though it's not my exact experience
i really really felt for her experience
and i did feel for you know the aspects
of that that are universal while so
appreciating the aspects that are very
specific to the pakistani culture and
everything else that comes with that and
i just can't wait to see the whole thing
expand
all right koi now now
what we're missing here though is this
isn't big enough you know how does this
tie into the multiverse in avengers
secret wars
talk only about that koi kang
is that you can have a contained story
that feels big and a big story that
feels small screw that koi you're not
talking about the things i wanted bigger
coins
is that she's cosmic but arguably one of
the most contained to herself characters
in the mcu well now she's the marvel
universe the reason i love spider-man is
because you always feel like he's a guy
that's just trying to get by spider-man
is always late for work he's always
trying to make sure he can undo a messed
up date with mj he's always trying to
make sure that he does the right thing
when he feels like he's the wrong guy he
always uses comedy as a defense
mechanism spider-man was invented in the
60s spider-man has been around for a
very long time it has gotten to the
point where it's very hard to retell
some of his stories and there are long
periods of time where spider-man comics
are not great because he's been around
for so long what i loved is that when we
got kamala khan in 20
i think she was in an issue or two of
captain marvel in 2013 her title started
in 2014. so we've had her for eight
years what i love i don't know google it
i don't i think you're
way off but i'm clearly the 70s i'm not
going to embarrass you so
what i love is that when we got this
character it reminded me of what it was
first like to discover peter parker
spider-man it's it's someone who is in
high school dealing with day-to-day
problems in extraordinary ways it's
someone like everyone has a high school
experience so we can identify with that
experience even as you know older dudes
but we also can learn from this
character and i love the weird awkward
moments of high school conversation
juxtaposing the moments of pure cosmic
power i love that as a dude especially a
white dude from boston i have very
little exposure to pakistani tradition
or to pakistani food or muslim culture
and i think that you can make any comic
book educational in a fun way to either
treat you about relationships morality
your world view or specifically cultures
and what i got out of miss marvel and
the reason i think the show was doing
such a good job is it makes you go hey i
get seven tenths of these things i would
like to learn more about the
three-tenths i don't without it feeling
like you're an other you're not othering
a thing you're not an outsider you go oh
this all makes sense please teach me
this and i think as americans that's
something we other very quickly and i
think it's really problematic how much
we like to go hey what if we do this
thing that feels normal all the time and
don't let things progress or learn and
this character it kind of makes you
learn and i really love that the show is
giving us a lot of things that feel
familiar while planting seeds to have us
grow with the character and that's what
i got out of the comic book so i love
that she has a small town like
spider-man that also has a big town like
jersey city i love that she has the
circle cue like peter has the daily
bugle i love that her family feels like
peter's mj harry gwen i love that her
family has the moral compass of an uncle
ben and not may but she has this net of
of comfort while also having the
struggle of being a teenager while also
being someone that doesn't look like
everyone else that's just like everyone
else and that i think is going to be so
important for kids nationwide and
internationally to feel seen for the
first time while also informing dumb
white dudes that like you know people
are people so i i think the show is
doing all the things i love about the
comics and it's doing it in a stylized
way that makes it unique and i love that
what i'm really
hoping yeah like
where is
when are we going to get off of earth
rambo going to show up in this one
g willow wilson is the writer who
brought her her solo title like so she'd
been introduced but the first solo book
which they used to cover up in there i i
love the mr wilson nod there and i
really love that they planted some of
that arc from that first run and again
terry dotson one of my favorite artists
is the background piece in her room that
made me happy i what i'm waiting for is
i'm really happy for you corey i'm sure
everyone is marvel everyone listening
right now was like i'm still listening
congratulations koi it's for me you won
clearly this show is for me
that's right
what what i am hoping for that and i
think the show will eventually go down
that route is this episode captured and
i imagine the rest of the series will be
you know kamala khan's perspective and
so with capturing her at this specific
point in her journey you know she's
feeling that a bit of like feeling
oppressed and a lot of it is cultural
clashes i feel like they're planting
seeds where it feels like a true
celebration of pakistani culture as well
because i could see that there could be
a different argument to be made with
some of the semi-generic setup because i
don't i don't feel like the execution
feels generic i think there's a lot of
great nuance to it that's something that
70 30. i think that's how we felt at the
end of the show i think you have to
start in 90 10. yeah and then you grow
it i mean start at the part where she
feels like the oppressed side and can't
be yourself and is having a clash with
the culture and family and and you know
all that jazz and then by the time you
get there because like i i liked the i
don't know how it is in the comics and
i'm curious to hear what you think
because i know they changed the power
set here to have the band be part of her
family legacy that gives her the powers
like everything she wanted is coming
through something that she that is
generational and i think that in and of
itself is honoring a part even though
it's sci-fi and [ __ ] it's honoring a
part of uh the pakistani culture i
imagine it'll eventually lead down that
road so i'm excited to see how it goes
there where it embraces it all you know
and i'm imagining that it'll go down a
path for her parents i don't know if her
parents will find out her true identity
i don't know the path that's headed down
now i know the feeling like her mom has
some knowledge that yeah no she they
alluded to that that she's like don't
touch those bands you know and as much
as we love her so far like abu is
nailing it like he's so the character of
the comics like we love the brother as
you know limited screen time it does a
lot but i i i will say my only negative
is too early to really quantify i love
that she's an inhuman and i love that
some of the body dysmorphia that comes
with being a teenager is kind of
representing the detergent
the terrigen myths i assume are not here
but when you talk about the generational
influence i would have had like you know
the inhuman element be part of like
maybe her ancestry and maybe she is an
inhuman that this this activates the the
the gene instead of the territories i
don't think they're touching the
inhumans i don't think they're gonna
mess with it i thought maybe after dr
strange spoilers for doctor strange
you've seen it two months ago and black
bolt i thought like maybe they were
gonna slowly reintroduce the inhumans by
way of like you know that little taste
that that touch of that it would be
unlikely now that we've seen how the
power manifests and it does kind of
remind me more of like you know some of
the more cosmic characters there are
quantum bands there are certain bands
from the 70s that not music fans bands
uh that tie into you guys chart in the
60s you guys tried the 60s clearly but
like though so i'm curious if those
things are generational if those things
are cultural or if there's going to be
anything that makes her unique on top of
the band that like the band has to
coincide with blankety blank because i
do think it's really important that the
terrorism miss activate something in her
and then again the body dysmorphia like
her being an insecure teenager and then
her having like crazy like physical like
almost cronenbergy and scary attributes
you don't get that as much with shiny
objects you don't get that as much with
like ooh sparkle cosmic so i think there
needs to be some of that somehow but it
hasn't bothered me enough that it's an
overall negative i know people are gonna
be uproarious but for me
it is my negative but i'm not closing my
mind to it i'm optimistic that the
reason they did it is to be seen and the
cost of trying to make stretchy hands
look good is prohibitive that's why john
krasinski had 45 minutes of screen time
clearly off camera
john i'm curious
as someone who's not said devotee of
comics uh-huh how do you feel about the
power set here without having this
pre-existing
like love
and meaning
but now just introduced
fresh
thoughts my
thoughts i have this review
[Laughter]
much like coy
i'm curious about the power setting and
it's a it's an idea like it's it's a
shift in idea and so now i'm sitting
here going okay it's up to them to make
something interesting out of that i
think they can i
you know i mean i wasn't expecting her
just to have a full-on like power blast
at the you know in a very public setting
in this episode so if anything moved
maybe a tad quick because of the change
to me it felt like that i mean i'm
finishing up agents of shield so that's
like prime this is my moment to sit here
and go canonize that you coward so that
you can use tara jin because that's such
a huge part of that show i can imagine
that maybe especially if we do get more
cross
cosmic
universal multiversal shenanigans
factoring in here that maybe that will
tie into why her power is the way it is
but my hope
is that it's got something to do with
the origin of that bangle and that maybe
there is uh something akin to like the
ancestral plane or something like that
that
maybe could explain it or something that
again ties back into culture because one
other thing that struck me about this is
i was reminded of shang chi in the early
moments where you know they're at home
and you're seeing home life and you're
just seeing that side of the culture and
then you know obviously the mcguffin is
also tied into that in some way but in
shanghai obviously you leave home and
you don't really come back and you're
mostly doing like cosmic crazy stuff so
i feel like here you've got an
opportunity to maintain the home life
across it but also tie that into the
origin of the bangle whatever her mom
might know and maybe make something
meaningful and
driven for that so while i am bummed to
lose that metaphor of like yeah this is
a physical change happening to my body
that also factors into just how i feel
about myself i could see them
making it something meaningful and i
hope that's what they do rather than
just being like it's a cool cosmic
mcguffin takes the end can i have one
can i have one last thought is that okay
you are on the thinnest device let me um
let me test shall run by you know you
know what coil yeah yeah you can you can
have it okay thank you for permission i
appreciate it one thing i'm interested
in is in the comics she's one of the
champions which is a modern rear
interpretation of a more street level
team and it's really politically charged
right now in the comic books the
champions comic is uh more about global
warming and people's rights and refugees
it's a lot more topical than maybe the
avengers because currently the avengers
are living in a celestial's head and
they're fighting vampires so it's not
exactly like linear so what i think the
champions do is they allow us as readers
to have a team that feels like it's
fighting for what we might experience in
real life while the avengers do their
cosmic stuff but what's interesting is
kamala is always going to feel straight
levels she represents jersey city she
represents all those things what's
interesting in the comics now is they've
already had the civil war thing happen
like a decade ago in the comics we had
civil war happen about a decade ago in
the movies now what happens legally in
the comic books is when the civil war
which is called the scovie accords in
the uh movies when that doesn't pass
when the scovia courts fail in the comic
books years later those same lawyers and
the same like bad guys try to pass it by
way of having people under 18 not have
uh the rights to be superheroes
basically they make it like child labor
laws effectively and they call it
kamala's law because kamala gets really
really injured and she's in a coma so
she doesn't have the ability to fight
for herself so people are using her name
against her very friends people are
using her name to persecute people she
cares about the fact that the cop that
was trying to get spider-man to mess up
is now in this and the fact that we're
getting a lawyer show right after this
and the fact that daredevil is
supposedly in everything for a while i
do think we're gonna see some
interesting follow-ups to civil war and
legal ramifications in this show that
set up certain things in the future like
the young avengers which i think is
going to be this universe's champions
parallel
maybe
read comics i don't think any of that
was necessary
why am i even here you took the words
right out of my mouth coy
greg's gonna cut it say save for say for
another time
oh my god
this is in love with this
what is trending i want this video
training kid who shows up in class and
you're like aren't we supposed to turn
in the assignment i i'm really proud of
the assignment you said we were gonna
have a quiz this week it's friday
where's the quiz
i thought we had a quiz it's cause he's
trying to get me to fight eric voss
every premiere if i have one genuine
criticism about this show is i
i uh
where's the mob rangers no
i took him out
[Laughter]
where's dj paulie d track super rose got
taken out i hope there's actual
consequences for when she does crazy
[ __ ] i mean they did set up the thing
with the cops still felt like a quirky
setup i think it's gonna be a ram i
think that's gonna be consequences i
think that's gonna be the undercurrent
it needs to feel truly consequent
because even the stakes in the moment
was just like oh my god all these people
in danger but no one really feels like
they're indeed they all got smacked up
like she rolled mjolnir through her face
still just like that's fine what i'm
saying like that was that might have
killed her i could i really see that
becoming a thing where it's like man
this footage is circulating oh she she
attacked the thing but i feel like
popular girl is going to come back and
be like no she saved my life and then
that'll yeah that'll be a thing yeah
it's not a heavy criticism it's just
more of a curiosity i'd like to be a
commentary in the police state and like
the overwatch of cameras and how we have
big brother that we implement ourselves
through social media that's what i want
to see
and miss marvel
fun
team street level fantasy i'd like to
talk about the fact that ring lights
account for more surveillance than
george orwell ever predicted i want to
invest for living in an age of pure
paranoia story about you know cell phone
addiction and pornography addiction and
miss marvel i i don't that's what i yeah
let's just do shame how are you in the
marvel
michael fassbender comes back as back
teenagers are in high school probably
watching just graphic imagery on their
phones being consumed and being falsely
diagnosed with adhd that's what i want
to see in miss marvel guys
yes take on the pharmaceutical
industrial complex yeah over prescribing
things that's right man we're gonna go
there they don't want us that's why they
stamp down supplements and vitamins they
don't want us to prevent disease they
just want to keep us up when they arrest
kamala khan we do it's political
policing issues of the industrial
complex that is churning out profits in
the prison system yeah see there's a lot
you can do i think that's episode two
and i feel like
they are only scratching the surface
right now guys
just getting started greg we're just
getting started hey kids
there's a lot to learn see we could have
ended this and now look what look what's
happening
thanks for watching guys leave a like
cameron is currently out of commission
we got to get this damn video up but i
wanted to shout out michael b today
michael b
should have a reaction up as well
for this miss marvel thing and this
guy's been doing such a good job lately
he deserves to be proper shouted out
because he's so good at what he does
so if you thought two white guys
reacting to miss marvel wasn't enough
get a third whitey in there before you
hop to blind wave to get four why more
people in there all the crap go to omni
media first michael b
michael bay b is what we like to call
right
he's become a really great friend of
mine as well um i'm really happy to know
you bud sometimes you text me too much
and then i get all upset when you stop
texting me and i'm like what the hell i
just like to be wanted
so dude
we got to keep this toxic relationship
going it's what's making us thrive
and before you all in your head no i
don't actually think you text me too
much
but sometimes you text a little too much
again i'm only joking
you don't text me that much that is a
sarcastic comment
but seriously you gotta get your [ __ ]
together do you not have any other
friends
that's me kidding
[Music]
i'm not kidding
but i am
[Music]